calling in from new york city christian
laettner how you been christian I've
been doing great thanks for having me
you bet you bet how much of these games
you've been taking in n-c-double-a
tournament I think I've watched every
game possible okay um I I only missed
one or two Duke games all year and then
I started watching the tournament on you
know Tuesday when they were doing the
first floor okay very good so you are
locked all the way in and my question
for you then is what happened to Duke in
your estimation Christian Duke ran into
a Michigan State team that does what
Michigan State teams do and that is
their physical they have some
upperclassman leadership they play great
defense they're well coached by is oh
and they rebound real well and that's
what Michigan State teams have done jeez
for the last 20 years so that's exactly
what they did on Sunday afternoon and
that's why they beat Duke what is his
coach Kay thinking today have you spoken
with him since the loss of all Christian
no I have not spoken to him at all okay
so what do you think is going through
his head today I think he's thinking man
I need to go have a little vacation you
know it's a long year he puts a lot of
effort in I'm sure he's highly
disappointed and I hope he's in Las
Vegas at the Wynn resort like I know he
likes to do and I hope he is I hope he's
resting a little bit because what that
guy does is remarkable every year and
the effort and the passion and the
intensity he puts into his team is it's
beautiful to watch and that's I still
love it and that's something I fell in
love with in 1986 and that's why I went
in played for him because I loved his
passion two questions on this one what
it what do you say then to those who say
that the Duke season was a failure
because they did not make a Final Four
with such a talented group of freshmen
man I haven't been hearing that but I
don't get on social media very often and
I don't listen to anything very much but
okay I didn't know people were saying
that it's disappointing that they don't
make the final four just because I want
them to make the final four very you
know so badly but I don't think they had
a disappointing season at all so I
disagree with people who are saying that
okay that's all I would say and there's
no other explanation needed
okay and what what is Coach K's game of
chance if you say you know he goes to
win disease he black I don't know I
don't know if he Gamble's at all but I
know he rests there and gets rest and
relaxation I've been out there working
before and he was there too and I went
over to his condo and he was just
sitting by the pool relax okay
all right Coach K can just let it all
hang out there Christian Laettner here
on the Rich Eisen show if you were a
senior on the team in Zion walked in the
door would how would you have greeted
him back in the day Christian well I'll
tell you how I greeted Grant Hill
okay well that work that works so with
Grant I immediately threw him the ball
and said come dunk on me let's see if
you can dunk on me and I and I would
stand under the hoop and I'd let him get
over to the three-point line and he'd
try to dribble in and dunk on me now I
don't think I'd do the same thing for
his eyes yes say that because one of my
favorite moments during the tournament
was talking about out whether somebody
actually had their feet moving trying to
take a charge on Zion and how it was a
bad call should have been a block not a
charge and I thought you got to get
credit just for standing in there right
oh my god did you saw how he knocked
over that skinny kid from Syracuse you
know a few months ago in Cameron I mean
the kid almost broke his neck and I know
but he gonna he's just a physical
specimen like no one has ever seen so
it's gonna be fun watching him play at
the next level
so did Grant Hill
ever dunk on you was he ever successful
yes once at the end of his sophomore
year which would be the end of my senior
year we stopped playing that little game
[Laughter]
that sounds like do you took a class in
Darwinism as well at Duke yes things
evolved and things change and things get
passed down and handed over and you know
his first freshman year and half of the
sophomore year maybe he couldn't duck on
me but by the end of the sophomore year
the reins and the control started to be
turned over for service Christian
Laettner here on the Rich Eisen show
I've never asked you this but I will now
how were you chosen to go on the Dream
Team how did that happen
for you I think it happened because I
was on a national team every year after
my freshman year so I think back then
the first year after the Olympics it was
the Goodwill Games or no the Pan Am
Games and then the Goodwill Games and
then the World Games do you remember
that rich sure of course and then the
Olympics so every year I was on the
national team and one year we went to
Mexico the next year we went to Puerto
Rico Puerto Rico and and then some other
year that I can't remember but I think
it happened because I was the Player of
the Year and we won two national
championships and the USOC saw my
commitment to you know their basketball
program so they rewarded me a little bit
a little bit for my commitment to them
now obviously you're known for your
confidence a swagger as well did you
have that walking into that locker room
for the first time as well into the
dream team yes sir no not at all I had
the swagger of a rookie uh-huh which
which they loved that's all when you're
a pro athlete that's all you want to see
you want to see that the rookies behave
the right way and act the right way and
I was very into acting like a rookie and
respecting those guys and not stepping
on anyone's
toes and that's another reason I think I
was chosen for the team because if you
have Shaq on that team you know he might
be someone that you had to play a little
more and and they knew that I would sit
quietly on the on the end of the bench
and not complain too much huh so you
weren't requiring the minutes is what
you were saying I was not requiring or
demanding any minute and I was along for
the ride and I was enjoying it and it
was still so much fun where does that
gold medal right now it's in my safe at
home how often you take it out never
come on never never I don't I don't even
think I've showed my children and more
than once and it was you know not even
me who did it someone else why why not I
don't know I don't know I mean I'd
rather I'd rather go up to the court up
to the you know the park with the hoops
at it and play basketball with my son
than show um old stuff so okay and then
now when you play hoops with your son
how old is your son now my son is 13 and
he just did something on the court the
other day that made me so happy because
um what's that you know the game isn't
all about dribbling and shooting and
passing some of the game part of the
game of basketball is reading the
defense and knowing where to go in terms
of spacing on the court and finally I
saw my 13 year old boy do something on
the court the other day that showed me
that he's learning the game and learning
about spacing and learning about you
know where to go in in relation of the
defense so that was a lot of fun for me
though he's here that's awesome did he
slap the floor to play defense that he
did stuff that he's not slapping the
floor yet you don't get to do that until
you go to do is there any part of your
game that he does have already yes the
one part of my game that he has already
is something that I've been drilling
into his head since he was six years old
and that is when you catch the ball son
do not dribble right away catcher
catch the ball face
and don't dribble save your dribble as a
great and that's something that my
father taught me and that's something
that Coach K used to yell at us every
day of our life is ook catching face
catching face don't dribble right away
I'm fantastic
Nez tall I mean how does he have your
height as well he's tall but there are
taller kids than him in his class and I
think he'll be somewhere between 64 and
67 cents
christian Laettner here on the Rich
Eisen show and hopefully is GPAs is Duke
worthy Christian right he's smarter than
me that's for sure okay there you have
it fantastic what are you doing with
Land O'Lakes this bot shot there's a
competition involving robotics and
basketball what can you walk me through
this here Christian well of course I'll
be in Minneapolis at the Final Four this
weekend and I'm doing stuff with Land
O'Lakes because Land O'Lakes is trying
to change the perception of modern
agriculture and encourage students to
pursue agriculture as a degree so we're
doing this neat little idea where they
they sent a box of metal parts to seven
schools and said build us a robot that
can take shots so on Sunday we're gonna
have a horse competition system where
there's robots trying to beat each other
and horse and do you think you can beat
the robot I do not think I can beat the
robot I've already seen one of the
robots and it's just incredible yeah but
I mean let's see let's see the robot go
ten for ten against Kentucky and hit the
game-winning shot that lives for decades
Christian let's see that happen right
well that would be neat but we don't
really want that to happen rich geez
well I mean that's a very dystopian view
of the future I agree with you Christian
but I'm just trying I'm trying to back
your play here you know what I'm saying
which is I'll be honest very troubling
for me and I'm I'm honest with you here
you know I'm a Michigan man and the Fab
five going down to you is something that
still stings it still stings to this day
to the point where my children watched
me root for Michigan State this weekend
and wondered what was going on and I
didn't have an answer for him to be very
honest with you I know isn't it hard
have to explain things like that to your
kids they don't have said they said to
me why do you hate Duke so much and I
wouldn't say well it's the coach can't
say it's the coach can't say it's the
player cuz I love the players ion I've
the one on the court you know I and I
try to explain to them just the anger I
still feel because of you Christian I
think that's basically it
well that's why the computer is awesome
sit them down at the computer and say
you see this kid from 30 years ago and
he beat our team a few times so that's
why I don't like them
so just YouTube it is basically what
you're saying yeah the YouTube therapy
from Christian Laettner I love it
hey Christian oh if you're ever in Los
Angeles but I'd love to have you in
studio one time as opposed to over the
phone well I'm not and I never will be
[Laughter]
I'm just teasing I'm just teasing I'm
not there once a year I was out there in
San Francisco maybe two years ago doing
a camp and I got a buddy coach who's out
in San Diego and he wants to have me
over so if I'm ever out there doing a
basket on campus at five I'd love that I
would greatly appreciate it last one for
you here what what advice you give Zion
before he heads to the NBA what advice
would you give him well I've already
said that he needs to be aware of the
social media phenomenon and stay off
that junk as much as he can and to get
to hire a company to handle this form
because his stuff is just gonna blow up
even bigger and bigger and bigger so you
should hire someone to handle all that
stuff and then my other suggestion would
be come back to Duke as much as we can
as much as you can so we can keep
developing your game keep developing
your jump shot and then I think he's
unstoppable he is amazing he does look
amazing and we'll see what happens at
the next level Christian thanks for the
call appreciate it
thanks a lot you go that's Christian
Laettner two-time NCAA champion the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience
you